see the theme song every damn day I'm
here to consider I'm here with Ryan back
Jordan Mendoza you want to call you
Jordi pizza and Natasha vain block we're
talking we're all poor we need money
oh I'm sorry are you not are you okay
I'm doing pretty good we're okay
save my money I invest I'd ever looking
abroad City clips to just relate to a
poor we are devastated up where we are
I'll be in Alana they're very poor on
the show neither not enough jobs but
they both have apartments and yeah
pretty nice apartment yeah pretty sick
apartment so let's play the first clip
it's called eight thousand
dollars starting started from the bottom
now we're here started from the bottom
now my whole team here started from the
bottom now we're here started from the
bottom now the whole team here started
from the bottom
[Music]
I got hit by a car and I got 8,000 bucks
what I almost died that's awesome that's
why it was great cuz like I used all
that money to move to New York City and
look at me now baby right now I just
realized that you said I almost died and
I said that's awesome right away yeah
that's what my subconscious meant one
time on 14th Street near the union's
Square subway stop
I saw $200 on the street I picked it up
and the guy next to me it wasn't his
money he just went when I was unemployed
things were very very tight and so I was
just like I need any job and I applied
to be a dog walker and I interviewed for
the dog walking position and if you
think that picking up is degrading
try not being qualified enough to pick
up I don't think it's gonna work
out it was like what I need this $15
just your general personality I really
have no idea what it was I don't know
okay I can see you walking like I'm not
I'm not walking any dodds and not
picking up your show I was like very
very much like I will do anything for
this money and I'm like happy - I like
animals I'm very pleased I once left my
entire backpack on a subway platform
forgotten and got on the subway doors
closed my backpack full of my laptop my
wallet back I did just my back it was
gnarly I went back it was gone and then
a like subway employee found it saw my
like work ID and brought it back to my
work let's see something stupid give it
back it's really move on to the next
clip yeah your next clip how many times
would you have to masturbate to fill a
backpack so tickets are 50 each
obviously we need an eighth okay Plus
drinks that's like 200 bucks total since
Todd wouldn't give me my paycheck you
took all of his office supplies listen
what I do at my place of work is none of
your goddamn business okay yeah I think
you really need to be fired really soon
love this song ah this is a slave song
it's not a slave song yes it is it's
widely known by the black community that
what a wonderful world is like a slave
song I totally forgot that you're like
the voice of the whole black community
it's a thing google it it's in a Fugees
song my cliffs like and I think to
myself it was like angry about it I feel
like when we ever talk about is black
people in slavery
hi I would like to return these items I
once owned them personally but I have
known you Spencer
your total comes to 135 dollars and 67
cents yes yes oh um you know we'd love
to get that in liquid cash yeah
okay what about my fishbowl of change
there's got to be like 30 or 40 bucks in
can you leave yeah we're gonna have
ending the convo what starts desperate
thing you've done for yet I don't know I
don't I don't really do that Jordan i
watch you eat food out of the trash yes
as a cost-saving measure I'm trying to
answer your question yeah no I bought
these oh my gosh oh my gosh pants yeah
oh yeah I got rid of those then I yeah
there's tons of stuff for clothes I
found on the street nothing wrong trash
pants I did once one of the crazy job I
had was I was a living doll inside of a
window display burning so I never tell
you with us inside entire holiday season
yeah you they never let you out of the
window I would lose they're for my shift
obviously and then but every day from
like the day after Thanksgiving to the
day like after New Year's I was inside
this window I love tourists walking
around thinking like wow what a quirky
red-light district I think it must have
been 20 bucks an hour or something you
didn't do anything no so we so people
could come into the window and take
photos with us Oh what were you doing
the window when no one was looking just
screaming just play the holiday music
and go
I do a lot
I tried to sell my underwear when I
first moved here and then they asked for
photos and the guy said never mind so I
didn't get so you sent you a photo yeah
no not my face just my body
you should look yourself up I bet you're
on it there's a thing called Wicky feet
I bet they it's like I'm on it people
have taken photos of my feet from like
sketch videos and I'm I have a very high
right how did you find my name once and
it was like nigga wiki feet yeah every
now that you go search your name on the
internet tell me where I am what
yeah wiki whoa whoa what the oh my god
it's so poor she is a force or a horse
nice feet print in parentheses pull up
these face wow this is um it's women
above it's an above average sketch
anyway I think that's good for the next
clip
please call me Ilana actually coming mr.
chemist oh okay I was just wondering
though are you finished I want you to
know that you already have the answers
unlock the solutions deep within you
get out of here oh my god please call me
Miss Wexler mix wax not closed on that
nail aren't you you made $400 in
ignition perfect baby girl you know we
can make Commission here yeah my interns
gather okay cats when I started this day
I had one goal and that was to get uh
deal but then I learned what Commission
is and now my goal is money money money
bitch now I'm gonna take lunch but I
need you guys to keep it on on on on on
please don't leave the building so that
you work and also I won't be able to
sign you back in cuz I'll be here okay
your fly's down
yeah yeah Nicole skalle is so good the
girl she kisses on the lips yes yes
internship where the they bought me
lunch one day like it was like I had to
go get lunch for this meeting that and
they're like oh and you can put an order
in yeah
and then they close the door when they
order like I brought the food and
they're like okay we'll take it thanks
and then they close the door and then
the meeting was two hours long and
someone didn't like what they got so
they switched and it was like cold at
that point and they were like you're
welcome and I was like this is horrible
I was like thank you so much this is
such a bit yeah truly thank you
where was that it was bad yeah I had a
great internship and to interned at a
very prominent Comedy Central show which
they do daily and it was the real see
what I did there and it was great but it
was before they started paying their
interns so I had to use all that money
that I got from almost dying in a car
crash Oh
yeah but it was great the coolest thing
that affronted I didn't get paid but I
joined the half marathon training squad
because my boss was like it's only the
executives and it's like four of us one
of them being Will Ferrell so I was like
alright I'll run so like every Sunday I
would meet up with them to run like ten
miles with Will Ferrell yes because I
was like I just want to like hang out
with Moe Pharaoh and he called me a
shark that's really cool yeah yeah he's
like just vomit after every I piss my
pants I knew that there is something
about body functions gonna come around
this high five and you know we'll wow
I'm sorry I'm sick and then I went to
the bathroom and cleaned up and you want
to put your piss on Will Ferrell I hope
he's not watching this be honest
do I have to donate that $8,000 I know
bitcoin is evil but it's like no more
evil than paper money it's like I was
like what about eating meat the meat
industry is the biggest contributor to
climate change I mean way more than
Bitcoin do you know that the fashion
industry burns the remainder of its
clothes at the end of every season to
retain its value mountains of clothes on
fire yeah not to mention that it's all
made by little children you know
Recycling's folks are you really
scrubbing out my food on containers and
peeling the labels off and melting the
plastic down to reform them into new
Adhan containers
oh dude garbage island is real mother
earth is like yeah
why has the news not covering this 24/7
don't even get me started on the news
the news is like what news is like hey
guys hey maybe focus on like important
issues like like recycling instead of
latching on to some stupid but really
understandable lay yeah issues and
flyers like way
yeah what also we are being listened to
all of the timing that we do on social
mean up for free we pay for through our
experience we're just data oh I feel so
much better thank you so much oh my god
you bought Bitcoin at the Cape yeah at
the peak which is a great place to buy
it where where is it now right now it's
just kind of the valley and up there not
at the peak still under the price yet
right now Zoe on my sex chef bought
about $15,000 and right now it's at
$3,000 which means it's like a perfect
time to buy if you're interested in
getting rich down the line it's a
long-term investment guys I'm not eager
to talk to people who are like for here
for short-term returns I just want
people to get rich with me so buy
Bitcoin right now thank you guys for
joining us on every damn day we're you
know we love broad city this is great
energy please join us in the backpack
challenge let's see how much come you
can fit in a backpack
[Laughter]
[Music]
you